la seule route vers la liberté en
afghanistan et celle menant à l'aéroport
de kaboul une forteresse gardée par les
talibans qui ont la gâchette facile
autant dire que l'évacuation des civils
n'est pas chose aisée
à jalalabad à l'est du pays au moins
trois manifestants sont morts une
douzaine d'autres ont été blessées leur
crime avoir brandi le drapeau national
afghan
des fauteurs de trouble selon les
talibans qui répètent qu'ils sont plus
modérés qui ne l'était il ya 20 ans un
message qui ne passe pas au royaume uni
boris johnson averti que les talibans
seront jugés sur les actes et non sur
les paroles on veut dire que du côté
russe du côté chinois il ya une sorte de
joie mauvaise à voir que les occidentaux
ont été vaincus et que après vingt ans
de guerre et après 2 milliards de
dépenses en afghanistan des occidentaux
ont subi une défaite stratégique majeur
à kaboul le retour du mollah baradar
l'un des fondateurs des talibans exilé
au qatar est célébrée
sur facebook l'ancien président ashraf
ghani depuis des émirats arabes unis
justifie sa fuite dit qu'il n'avait pas
le choix et qui négocie un retour
possible au pays
mais chez à des dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres de ces tractations
diplomatiques les afghans tentent de
partir coûte que coûte une poignée parmi
eux atteint la turquie arman amadi 10
est en marche vers istanbul il est prêt
à tout sauf à rebrousser chemin
j'ai un métier je suis coiffeur j'ai été
forcé de venir ici légalement il ya la
guerre dans mon pays sans cette guerre
j'y serais resté affirme-t-il malgré
leur faible nombre l'union européenne
craint le pire au sud non il ne faut pas
attendre d'avoir des migrants à nos
portes on doit les aider avant dit la
commissaire européenne
ce sont les pays européens qui eux mêmes
ont mis en avant la possibilité d'une
crise migratoire et en faisant cela ils
ont fait une erreur stratégique en
indiquant talibans quelles étaient leurs
faiblesses nasa
pour cette famille l'enfer est loin
derrière
ils sont au canada et ne cachent pas
leur joie
monsieur sadate profite de la vue depuis
sa chambre d'hôtel à toronto incrédule
et chant c'est à la fois nous parlons de
20000 nous espérons faire encore plus
parce qu'on parle de 6000 personnes
qu'on identifiait comme ayant des liens
directs ou indirects au canada
l'occident a perdu la guerre il ne
faudrait pas qu'il perde l'honneur en
refusant d'accueillir ceux qui ont
combattu à ses côtés ici à ce
mitraillage radio canada montréal